hey there and Welcome to our video on
devops engineer roles and
responsibilities if you're new to the
tech industry or just curious about the
role of devops in software development
you have come to the right place so what
exactly is devops in simple terms it's a
set of practices and tools that help
developers and operational team work
better together releasing software
faster with higher quality at its core
devops is about breaking down barriers
between development and operations and
creating a culture of collaboration that
focuses on delivering value to customers
as quickly and efficiently as possible
of course this is a vast over
simplification and there are many
different aspects of devops that we
could spend hours diving into but for
now let's focus on some of the key
responsibilities of a devops engineer
who is the person responsible for
implementing and overseeing devops
practices and processes but before we
begin if you're new to the channel and
haven't subscribed already consider
getting subscribed to Simply learn to
stay updated with all the latest
Technologies and with that Bell icon to
never miss an update from us having said
that the demand for devops professionals
has overgrown in recent years as more
and more companies adapt devops
practices to improve their software
development and delivery processes so
are you ready to advance your
professional career to the next level
taking our step-by-step simply learned
program in devops in collaboration with
IBM will help you start your devops
journey that will prepare you for the
devops engineer role in order to match
your skill set market demand this devops
training program is designed in
collaboration with Caltech ctme our
Cutting Edge branded learning combines
live online devops certification classes
with interactive labs to give you
practical experience this post-target
program covers topics including git
GitHub Docker CI CD practices using
Jenkins kubernetes and much more so what
else can you expect from this program
well this devop trading program will
cover skills like devops methodology
continuous integration devops and Cloud
deployment Automation and you'll also
get hands-on experience with the latest
tools and techniques including terraform
Maven and symbol Jenkins Docker junit
and many more this program will cover
industry projects like Docker Rising
junkins pipeline deploy angular
application and Docker container
branching development model and many
more exotic projects so if you are
looking to pursue your career as a
devops engineer and acquire skills that
will prepare you for your job consider
enrolling in this intensive training
program we will leave the link in the
description box below make sure you
check that out so without any further
Ado let's get started with today's topic
firstly let us understand what is devops
now devops is a software development
approach that emphasizes collaboration
Automation and communication between
development and operations team it aims
to streamline the entire software
development life cycle by integrating
and optimizing processes tools and
methodologies it encourages the culture
of shared responsibility where
developers and operations team work
together closely throughout the entire
software development life cycle from
planning and coding to testing
deployment and monitoring
now the question is who is a devops
engineer well you got it right a devops
engineer is a professional who combines
software development expertise with
operations knowledge to facilitate
collaboration Steam and processes and
improve software delivery and
infrastructure management within an
organization a devops engineering role
is to bridge the gap between development
and operations team enabling efficient
and reliable software development and
deployment practices
but the question is how to become a
devops engineer what are the skills that
you need to possess to become a good
devops engineer well a devops engineer
possess a wide range of skills including
proficients in scripting and programming
languages knowledge of various tools and
Technologies expertise in
systemadministration dot platforms and
containerization Technologies as well as
strong problem solving and communication
skills are necessary firstly having a
good coding knowledge well tools like
Confluence jira git these tools can
support and enhanced collaboration and
project management within a devops
environment next having a good knowledge
on deployment tools are also necessary
now tools like dcos provides
orchestrationization capabilities for
distributed applications Docker enables
containerization for consistent and
scalable deployments and AWS offers a
broad range of cloud services for
infrastructure provisioning scalability
and managed Services next you need to
have a good knowledge on operations
tools as well now chef and ansimil focus
on infrastructure automation and
configuration management while
kubernetes specializes in container
orchestration and management these tools
are utilized in devops to automate
various aspects of software like
development life cycles including
infrastructure provisioning
configuration management application
deployment and scaling moving ahead you
need to have a strong grip on monitoring
tools nagios Splunk and dated dog are
three commonly used tools in the field
of monitoring and observatability now
each rule serves a specific purpose in
monitoring and managing system and
applications nag your specializes in
infrastructure and application
monitoring Splunk focuses on log
analysis and data visualization datadog
provides comprehensive monitoring and
analytic capabilities in Cloud
environments these tools play a crucial
role in maintaining the health and
performance of systems and applications
moving ahead you need to have a good
knowledge on Jenkins and code ship now
Jenkins and code chips are both
essential tools and demo practices
Jenkins is a flexible and extensible
automation server that supports
continuous integration testing and
deployment on the other hand core ship
is a cloud-based CI CD platform that
offers Simplicity and ease of use
particularly for cloud native
applications both these tools contribute
to improving development productivity
and code quality and finally having a
good knowledge on testing tools like
selenium junit are necessary for a
devops engineer junit is primarily
focused on unit testing and automated
testing of java code while selenium is
geared towards functional testing and
automation of web applications both
these tools play critical roles and
devops workflow contributing to faster
feedback Cycles improve code quality and
Reliable Software releases
so these are some of the main and
important skills that you need to
possess as a devops engineer before
moving ahead let's take a minute and
listen to the experiences of our
Learners who have enrolled in the devops
pgp program which has proven to be
highly beneficial for many aspiring
engineers and professionals leading them
to achieve New Heights in the field of
devops
I started my It Journey with Accenture
three years ago I joined the asset Cloud
architect there I worked with AWS and
Azure Technologies looking for higher
paying job and devops seem the right
career choice so I decided to go with
the postgraduate program in devops in
collaboration with Caltech ctme the
course was divided into modules
and we had assignments
I was really impressed by how many job
interviews I landed after I added the
certification to my portfolio and now I
am earning 40 more than my previous job
it didn't only boost my career but also
my confidence
well now comes the main part what
exactly are the day-to-day roles and
responsibilities of a devops engineer
now a devops engineer play a crucial
role in Bridging the Gap between
development and operations team as we
discussed earlier so here are some of
the top five roles and responsibilities
of a devops engineer in detail first on
the list we have collaboration and
communication now devops engineer of a
state effective communication and
collaboration with development and
operations team the actively participate
in meetings and discussions to align
goals and expectations now as a devops
engineer you need to engage in regular
meetings and discussions regular
engagement ensures that they are up to
date with ongoing projects challenges
and goals enabling them to better align
their efforts and contribute effectively
regular engagement ensures that they are
up to date with ongoing projects
challenges and goals enabling them to
better align their efforts and
contribute effectively actively listen
and understand the requirement concerns
and feedback now when engaging with
development and operations team day offs
Engineers practice active listening they
pay close attention to the requirements
concerns and feedback expressed by team
members from both the sites by
understanding their perspectives pain
points and suggestions devops Engineers
can better assess the needs of their
teams and collaborate to find suitable
Solutions frustrated effective
communication channels now devops
Engineers take the initiative to
establish and maintain effective
communication within the organization
this often involves settling up
dedicated chat platforms like slack
Microsoft teams or collaboration tools
like jira to Foster better collaboration
and ensure that information flows
smoothly between the teams and finally
encourage cost functional collaboration
now day of Engineers recognize the value
of cross-function collaboration and
knowledge sharing among the team members
they actively encourage them from
development and operations team to
collaborate exchange ideas and share
their expertise second on the list we
have infrastructure Automation and
configuration management now demos
Engineers focus on automating
infrastructure provisioning and managing
configurations using certain tools they
Define infrastructure as code enabling
efficient deployment and scaling of
resources
now as a devops engineer you have to
identify the infrastructure requirements
effectively now devops Engineers work
closely with development teams to
understand the infrastructure
requirements of the application this
involves analyzing the needs of
applications in terms of Computer
Resources Storage security networking
and scalability by gathering all these
requirements devops engineer can ensure
that infrastructure is provisioned and
configured to meet the application
specific need and future growth write
infrastructure automation scripts and
templates now once the infrastructure
requirements are identified devops
Engineers use automation tools and
techniques to define the desired state
of infrastructure components the right
scripts and templates that specify how
the infrastructure should be provisioned
configured and managed
automate the provisioning configuration
and management of servers well devops
Engineers leverage infrastructure as
Code Orange IAC principles to automate
the provisioning configuration and
management of servers networks and other
infrastructure resources they use tools
like and symbol chefs or puppet to
automate the deployment and
configuration of infrastructure
components and finally regularly update
infrastructure code now devops engineer
uses Version Control Systems like get to
track changes collaborate with team
members and manage different versions of
infrastructure code by regularly
updating and versioning infrastructure
code devops Engineers can easily track
and reverse changes whenever necessary
now third on the list we have continuous
integration and continuous deployment or
CI CD in short now devops Engineers are
responsible for establishing and
maintaining cicd pipelines which enable
developers to integrate code changes
seamlessly and deploy applications
rapidly
so for that they have to set up a
version control system now Version
Control System like git play a crucial
role in devops by providing a
centralized repository for managing code
and tracking changes setting up a
Version Control System involves creating
a repository initializing it with the
code and defining branching and merging
strategies
configure a build server now a build
server automates the process of
compiling testing and packaging
application code tools like Jenkins and
gitlab cicd allows you to Define build
pipelines that specify the steps to be
executed these pipelines typically
involve tasks such as pulling code from
repository compiling source code
generating artifacts and packaging the
application
next automate the deployment process now
automation of the deployment process is
crucial for achieving rapid and
consistent software releases
containerization tools like Docker
provide a lightweight and portable way
to package application and their
dependencies Docker containers can be
created and deployed consistently across
different environments ensuring
consistency between development testing
and production Define an inverse quality
Gates and monitor cicd kpis quality
Gates ensure that the code meets
predefined quality standards before it
is promoted to the next stage of the
cicd pipeline automated testing
including unit test integrated test and
end-to-end test integration test and
end-to-end test help catch bugs and
validate the functionality of the
managing applications and finally
measuring K pairs of the CI CD pipeline
provide insights into its performance
and help identify areas for improvement
well next we have monitoring and
performance optimization now day of
Engineers monitor system performance
identify and
infrastructure and application Stacks
whenever necessary they Implement
monitoring tools to collect and analyze
metrics logs and places so for that
select and configure monitoring tools
now monitoring tools like Prometheus or
graphene can be used to collect and
visualize these metrics allowing tapes
to identify bottlenecks or optimize
processes and enhance the overall
efficiency of the CI CD pipeline
also they have to collaborate with
development and operations team to
fine-tune application performance
so continuously optimizing the
infrastructure which will ensure High
availability scalability and reliability
of that application and finally we have
security and compliance now deox
Engineers play a critical role in
implementing security measures and
ensuring compliance with industry
standards and regulations they were
closely with security teams to Define
and Implement security controls
throughout the software delivery
pipeline so they have to continuously
collaborate with the security teams to
identify and Define security
requirements and controls and Implement
security measures such as vulnerability
scanning access management and secure
configuration they have to continuously
integrate security testing and code
analysis into the CI CD pipeline
and monitor for any sort of potential
security risk or breaches and respond
promptly to mitigate any identified
vulnerabilities
so these were some of the main or top
five roles and responsibilities of a
devops engineer I hope you understood
that and with that we have come to the
end of today's session guys I hope you
found this tutorial informative and
helpful if you have any further queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
today's session in the comment section
below and a team of experts will be more
than happy to help resolve all your
queries at the earliest
until next time thank you and keep
learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here